hey 42 here life is like a box of
chocolates
it's far too expensive and they only
enjoy about 50% of it but when it comes
down to it what's on earth or anywhere
else is life from our perspective water
and rocks and spoons and slippers are
all inanimate objects but how do we
decide what is alive and what is not is
there a point where the chemistry
suddenly crosses over would we recognize
an alien species if we saw it and if you
really really believe hard enough can
you bring something to life when you're
trying to define life you realize that
it can't be black and white it's like
asking how many trees do you need to
make a forest what's the point where a
snack becomes a meal and how many cuts
what's your own before you have a
problem there is no one criteria that we
can use to define life and we also must
remember that we have an obvious
tendency to focus on our planetary
carbon-based existence when there are
actually countless of a worlds that
could have created living beings from
any other elements such as silicon or
iron so if we accept that life is a very
gray area then we must focus on key
facets to determine if something really
is alive firstly complexity
Confucius may have said life is really
simple but we insist on making it
complicated but then again he often put
his pants on backwards on newsy row
about molecular biology also life needs
to practice homeostasis meaning that it
has an equilibrium for its internal
conditions things like temperature pH
value glucose levels etc so what about
life on Earth what piece of chemical
creativity created the winding path from
molecule to monkey to mo well about 4
billion years ago chemistry became
complicated and reactive enough to start
what we think of as like the very
surprising thing is
this is not the most important nor most
improbable event you could easily get
some form of life if you had a planet of
a similar chemistry and conditions to
ours and there are most certainly plenty
of these planets out there in the
universe but on earth once we have life
it just sat around as prokaryotes a very
simple form of cell with no nucleus sort
of a complicated structures inside it
ask these basic cells they couldn't
really change as it was almost
impossible to take in enough energy to
make any major upgrades it would be like
trying to install ps4 games on a gameboy
you'd need a whole room just the AAA
batteries so they stayed like that just
little dribbling morons for about two
billion years then a very unlikely thing
happened according to one theory archaea
are one of the simple cell types that
still exist today in some extreme
environments two billion years ago an
archaea let a bacterium inside it
possibly through a hole in its cell wall
and against all odds
both survived the bacteria became what
we know as mitochondria the reason this
was so important is that these
mitochondria have an electric charge
which for their size is like a lightning
bolt it was only once they had this new
pimped-out engine that cells had the
energy to become more complex and spawn
all the life that we see around us today
except squirrels no one knows where
squirrels are from part of the reason
behind this mitochondria theory is that
every living thing shares almost 50% of
the same DNA with archaea a two billion
year old self all right then so if we
have a very good guess at how life
actually began is there anything we can
do to replicate it and start a game of
cellular sims in a petri dish well we're
actually not too far off guessing life
started at NASA's Ames Research Center
in California they set up the best space
light conditions that they could by
turning the lights off and cranking up
the air
listening well to put it in simple terms
anyway they then talk commonly occurring
molecules of carbon and nitrogen and
exposed them to radiation managing to
produce three key chemicals that are
needed for RNA and DNA showing that it's
possible that the components of life
could have come in on an asteroid in the
early stages of our planets development
okay but a bit of space chemistry is
hardly exciting what about real
Frankenstein cells that we can put
together from bits of leftover lunch
well dr. craig Venter a pioneer in
genetics spent 15 years along with his
team sequencing the DNA of a bacterium
and then artificially reproducing it
along with a watermark so that they
could track it they chose mycoplasma
genitalium
the smallest bacteria in the world and
they injected their code into an empty
cell after working out how to get rid of
its original DNA these new artificial
cells successfully reproduce showing
that the process actually works but we
still don't really understand these
genitalia so basically we've created
life but we're not quite sure how this
bacterium has under 500 genes whereas
humans have 20,000 and after 500 or so
we're not sure what a quarter of them
actually do aside from the fact that
they are very necessary making life is
one thing but controlling it is a whole
other step so it'll be a while before
you can pop down the pet store and order
up a monkey with lizard eyes and bat
wings
finally let's lis boring gold reality
behind and have a quick wander into the
hypothetical we're made of carbon but
what other kinds of materials could
create life and what conditions would
they need to exist silicon is probably
the most likely candidate since it can
create molecules that are large enough
to carry the massive amount of
information you need to encode a life
form what more we already have a hint at
its existence here on earth since a type
of algae called diatoms have a cell wall
made up of silica just don't tell too
many people or carbon-free dieting will
become a
vadym and caesar which has proposed a
possible spaceborne
life form in the form of dust suspended
in plasma in certain extraterrestrial
conditions the dust could become charged
and begin to self-organize into
complicated structures and from there
who knows what the dots would evolve
into presumably some kind of dust buster
all in all you are unbelievably lucky to
be alive it's not just a peculiar
combination of genes that makes you you
but the overwhelming amount of chance of
good fortune that got us from little
dots in a vast molecular soup two big
fat walking talking one monkey's thanks
for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2 but there's a mud equally as
despicable as adult hitler yet very few
people even know of his existence
the humble caterpillar is one of the
most mined shatteringly incredulous
creatures on planet earth